I don't know why women just don't get it
because is it women or me could just say
me
you know the only everyone to say you
want to say you but I'm just saying
women as in general because it is
because 35
um
right you can be looking good at 35 and
you can get with a man at 35 and say
you're gonna have
you're gonna get with this man you're
gonna have a five-year relationship with
him and then start having kids
think about your 35 you're going to
start having kids at 40. it's not going
to be the same
being
with my peers and having children it
doesn't matter how good you look it
doesn't matter about your body because
you can't beat
biology
is gonna happen